Dragon Spirit, the new legend, the blue dragon must rise again.
Dragon Spirit, the new legend.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
It's called The New Legend because this isn't the same as the other Dragon Spirit games that came before it that you also didn't know existed.
Is that true?
You guys didn't know this was a franchise?
Oh, I thought it was just one of those situations where the first game in an IP gives itself a subtitle to sort of like self-fulfill it becoming a franchise.
Yeah, there's sort of like a prologue at the beginning and I thought that was the old legend.
Right. And I think both are valid responses and not knowing didn't matter, right?
It's not like, oh, should I go back to the arcade and play that one first before I can play the NES game?
It's not that kind of situation, right?
But there is a hefty plot to the game and a story behind it and everything and a reason for doing things,
which is good because this is a shmup and a lot of times it's just you're in a spaceship and you got to fight off an alien invasion, right?
This is kind of interesting that it's taking like some things you might see in an RPG and bringing them to the shmup genre story-wise, not mechanically.
Yeah, you're like a guy that can turn into a dragon and you then fight things as a dragon.
A dragon shmup.
So that's new, right?
It's true. It's not a helicopter.
It's not a spaceship.
It's not a guy with a gun.
It's going to sound stupid because essentially in the NES, it's just all projectiles anyway, so it doesn't really matter.
But just humor me.
Do you prefer your shmups when they're vehicles or when they're like the weirdest things you can possibly think of?
It's hard to really say because shmups are kind of all over the place with whether or not I like them,
but I really liked this as a change of pace to vehicles.
I'm not saying that I'd like, oh, it's got to be an animal or a dragon,
but it's just like it's nice to see something different for sure.
Vehicles are like the meat and potatoes, so you always need to have that.
But every once in a while, you can have an animal as a little treat.
Yeah, it's nice that shmups aren't afraid to just have the thing you play as be whatever.
I would like a game in the Ace Combat style, but it's a dragon instead.
That would be interesting.
You have a realistic dragon simulator.
Isn't that like Panzer Dragoon?
No, because Panzer Dragoon's on rails.
Oh, is it? I didn't know.
It's like Star Fox.
Well, you're right.
You're right. Okay, so to get right into the game, I'm not trying to like...
This is going to sound way too hype-y, but this is the first NES game in a while,
and we've been playing a lot of them.
We're at over 300 now.
The first time in a while that I was legitimately surprised by something that an NES game did
that hasn't been done before on the console, obviously.
And that is that when you start the game, you're given this prologue, as Joe mentioned,
and you go right into the action, and then based on whether or not you defeat the boss at the end of this stage
determines what your difficulty level is, what kind of dragon you're going to be,
what happens to the story in the game.
It's basically like a tutorial meets a decision tree, right?
It's crazy, and I wonder if you guys had the same thing of like,
huh, what just happened?
Like, I've never seen that before.
I've never seen that before at all, even outside of the NES.
Like, these specific circumstances.
Like, the, whether or not, or however well you perform in the first level,
I guess that binary is you die or you survive,
it just decides the game you're going to play,
and you may not even know, maybe it's in the manual, I didn't read it,
the way that I experienced it,
you may not even know that there's an alternative.
I know that it gives it like, gold dragon edition,
or like, blue dragon edition after that,
but that whole framing is just wild to me.
I actually didn't know.
I loved that prologue.
I was like, this is really cool, because it's like, it's like before you even start the game,
you like, play a slice of like, the ancient history of this world,
and I thought that was really neat.
I didn't know there was an alternate way to play this,
like, if you died.
Not to brag, but I didn't die.
But yeah, that's awesome.
Like, what's that like?
Not suggesting that you guys died,
but does anybody know what that's like?
It's a subtractive thing.
Like, you get like a lesser game,
which is weird to look at it that way,
but that's sort of what it is.
You get less levels,
all the enemies die in one hit, for the most part,
and you have a different color dragon.
Yeah, you become the gold dragon,
and he's also faster,
and can take more hits.
So it's the easy mode of the game.
They've assessed that you weren't able to beat
what they consider the standard game, right?
Like, you died in the very first level
of the game that they set up,
so they've decided,
yeah, they've decided that you need to, like,
cool down a little.
And you can be the ultra-powerful golden dragon instead.
I do think it's strange that
they're removing entire levels from this one.
Like, they're not gonna give you the complete game.
Probably just makes sense to give you
the stronger, easier dragon
that just kind of, like,
is, you know, OP.
But at the same time,
I guess, like, it affects the story, too,
which was, like, the thing I had to do
as soon as I realized
that there was a branching pad thing.
I had to go back and die
to see what it's like.
Like, are they actually gonna change the cutscenes?
And they do. That's amazing.
That is awesome.
Yeah, you're in some, like,
like, you're in the darkest timeline
where, like, you're the kid
that you play as,
but, like, now is dad's dead or something.
I couldn't really follow the story
in the vague details
of all the characters that you meet
and are named in the first, like,
however many minutes, but it's presenting itself as, like,
oh, this is what happens
if all that stuff went wrong
because, yeah, you failed.
And, Mike, to your point about missing
the, like, missing entire levels,
I'm not even necessarily seeing it as, like,
oh, yeah, they took out these levels
because they're just trying to make everything easier
so you have to play less game.
I almost feel like,
seems like that's, like,
your reward is, like,
yeah, you can play the easier thing,
but you're not gonna get all the content.
Or, if you do well in that first one,
you're rewarded. You get a harder game,
but you're rewarded with, like,
the better story and more levels.
Yeah, no, that's a great way of putting it,
that ultimately, you know,
you will find out
that there's another branching path.
Sorry, Joe. You should have known.
You will find that out,
and then you will go for, like,
the, you know,
the normal mode, I guess,
is, right? It's not,
the normal mode is the blue dragon mode,
and the easy mode, the gold dragon.
It's not like blue dragon mode
is hard mode
in what a shmup might look like.
It's all perspective. But wait,
how do you find out eventually?
No, you would have found out
by reading the manual,
or just from, like, you know,
like, spending enough time
with the game that, like,
one time you beat the first level
or one time you die,
you know, like, it would be revealed to you.
There's no, like, moment in the game
where they're like, I got you.
If only you could go back in time
and save your father
or something. But, you know,
there is something to the locations
that you travel to
in this game that, like,
are we a dragon
and traveling through
time and space?
Like, we start in the,
what the game, what the manual refers to
as the Paleozoic era.
So we are literally starting,
you know, long before humans.
Then you go to volcanoes,
jungles, graveyards.
Everybody knows that there was,
you know, the graveyards is, like,
when everything was dead.
And then you go to caves.
This is the natural progression
of the earth. Glaciers, right?
Now it's the Ice Age.
Deep Sea, the glaciers melted
and now the, you know,
everything's water. Then the Dark Quarters,
we're all expecting that
to come soon when the Dark Quarters are here.
And then last, the Dark Castle,
which is really just, like,
a thing in the Dark Quarters.
So, is it, like,
over a, like,
eons of time?
I didn't get, I didn't get that
from the story, obviously,
but, like, what's the,
it does feel like that
from, like, where you're going.
The Paleozoic era is, like,
just east of San Bernardino.
No, it's funny.
I don't have a response for that,
but that's funny. It's funny that you're
saying this, though, Mike,
because I didn't think
it was eras either,
but when I played that prologue,
that's what I thought the game was going to be.
Like, the prologue made me think,
like, wow, this is going to be, like, a cool little,
like, the history of this world
and I'm going to play through, like,
each part of,
like, the legendary history.
But then it didn't end up being that,
but it is funny
that you were asking that.
And inside each
of those levels, too, there is
gameplay that matches
those locations.
So, in the Paleozoic era,
the first level
after you determine
your mode, there are these,
you know, I don't know if they're
meteors or fireballs,
I believe they're fireballs,
that are being shot at you
the entire stage.
You're just going to have to dodge them.
You're not sure where they're coming from
or wherever. And then it's revealed
that at the end, the boss at the end
of the stage has been shooting
those fireballs at you.
That's a nice touch.
There's also, like,
what is it? It's like,
you shoot away
these vines
and stuff and then that
creates a path
for you. It's all destructible,
but you must shoot at it.
That's all, like, nice.
I felt like every level
had something
that was, like,
elevated beyond
just, like, okay,
here's some more new enemies.
It was, like, new things you had
to think about. Like, that webbing
or they're, like, I think in that
same level with the vines
or whatever, there's,
like, these things that fly around
and leave trails
of, like, honeycomb
that you have to shoot through
or otherwise it'll kill you
and, like, that really
changes up the gameplay
a lot. But,
yeah, every level has stuff like that.
just with,
like, presentation stuff
too, like, we don't talk
about it often because none
of us are, are really,
like, don't really have
the vocabulary to talk about
music all that much.
But also, it's got some
bangers in here. It's,
it's got some, some good stuff.
Definitely something that I clocked
right away and I especially,
just, just because it's me,
I've got to say, maybe my favorite
of all time pause sound.
It, like, it, like,
goes with the music.
It's, like, it's beautiful. Well,
don't tease us,
you know. I'll try to play it
here. Yeah, play it right here,
yeah. And what it,
you know, what it might lack
in, in graphics
compared to
some other shmups or whatever,
it doesn't really,
like, the cutscenes bring some great,
some great sprite work
to it. And,
you know, everything is,
I think, especially,
the bosses, like,
everything's cool. It's just,
you know, sometimes it's,
like, the background is a solid black
or a solid blue.
You know, there's, like,
moments like that.
But I think, because the actual levels
themselves, like,
play along to their theme
and it's not just, it's not just,
like, oh, we're gonna design these
backgrounds to be,
like, super vivid jungles,
but you can't interact
with them. Because it's the reverse,
it actually gets, like,
a pass, right?
Yeah, and I think that there are,
like, there are definitely
a lot of those times
that you're describing where it's,
like, a black background with,
like, with,
like, items on it
or, like, patches of grass
and trees on it. But then there are some
that are, like, very,
I don't know, a lot of the,
a lot of the stages
are very, like,
the art, it feels very,
like, epic and it feels like
you're not, this isn't just a re-skin shmup,
it feels like you're a dragon
flying through a fantasy land,
you know? Yeah,
I also think that, I mean,
maybe this is me giving it
too much credit
because we're, we're heaping a lot of praise
in this game so far,
um, but it,
there's a lot of shmups
that have very busy backgrounds
that can just completely
mess with
your vision,
trying to see all these,
uh, projectiles that you're trying
to avoid or, like,
enemies blending into,
uh, the brown ground
and, so I think that,
like, it's also just good
for, um,
the, how coherent
the field looks
with some of this
minimalist, uh,
stuff here.
Yeah. Now,
the, you know,
the thematic, uh,
locations, or whatever you want
to call them, the gameplay mechanics
working in their favor,
uh, sometimes that can also lead
to very frustrating
moments, though, too, where it's like,
yeah, this is designed
in a really neat way,
but you've made it,
uh, very challenging,
uh, to the player,
regardless of their,
uh, you know, like,
skill level or whatever,
uh, and I'm thinking specifically
when I got to the cave
and the cave continues
to, like, close in on you
and create really
just a narrow corridor
where conveniently
all of the enemies
can go through
the, the parts of the cave
that will kill the dragon,
but you can't go through them,
so they're able to go
both around you
and come directly at you
and you have to kind of
just carefully,
like, you know,
it's not a fluid motion
to your controls
on the D-pad, right?
You kind of stutter
a little bit if you just tap the right,
you just dance,
you take, like,
pyramids, that,
yep, that's the cave one as well.
Okay, yeah, so,
I guess we're talking about the same thing.
The pyramids come out
and then just become
part of the,
uh, the terrain,
really, uh, that same,
like, you don't touch the,
the cave wall
because it'll kill you,
same with these pyramids,
but these sort of, like,
blink in and out,
and it,
it's, it's not like
it's hard to avoid,
but sometimes, if you're trying
to dodge other things,
it becomes hard to avoid,
uh, so yes,
I think that that could,
that, that got a little annoying.
I wouldn't say
it was just, like, it,
it killed my entire
playthrough, though.
Yeah, the,
the motion thing,
like, didn't bother me so much,
uh, but yeah,
I, I did, the,
the pyramids, and,
like, a couple of other instances
like that, where there's,
like, there's,
like, obstacles coming out
of the ground that you're not,
like, sure, like,
totally sure where it's coming from.
Yeah, exactly, will this hurt me?
Or, a little bit of a
different situation,
but, like, towards,
like, the end, and, like, one of the last
couple levels, there are dead ends
that, like, yes,
you can normally see
just before it's too late,
but, like,
it's very close to
when it's too late,
so, like, that, that's kind of annoying,
but, I, I guess I didn't focus
on that stuff as much
because, compared to a lot of shmups,
this one felt a lot,
it's not easy,
but it felt a lot more
accomplishable to me
to, like,
get good at this shmup
than most shmups.
Like, I,
I don't know, something about it
felt that way. I do want to talk about that,
Joe, because there is something
fair about the game.
Like you said, it's not easy,
and, I,
I'm talking about the blue dragon mode
that I think is fair,
not the gold one,
which, honestly is,
you know, is easy.
Uh, yeah, the,
the blue dragon mode,
it's fair, and I think what I determined,
and this is not scientific,
I didn't go back
and study every shmup
we've played, but I think it has to do
with the scrolling speed.
Like, it doesn't,
it doesn't scroll,
like, too fast,
it gives you enough time
to, like, recognize enemies
entering the screen.
The enemies never just,
like, ambush you,
like, six at a time
from one side,
like a, like a Galaga game,
like would. You don't have those kinds
of moments in here, so instead,
it's more like,
just, you know,
field control, and making sure that
you know where everything is on the screen,
and, you know,
I'm not saying that it, like,
moves in a loading screen-like pace
where it just, like, slowly starts to reveal
the rest of the level. It is scrolling,
but it just feels like
it's so much slower
compared to,
like, Life Force
and, you know,
Gun.Smoke
and other games where, like,
you know, you were in control
of your character and could move
completely through the screen,
but you can't control
how fast it scrolls,
so that matters
in these games. I mean,
I think that the,
it's almost,
like,
hard to watch
how slow the game scrolls,
but, I say that
in more of,
like, a, this doesn't feel
right sort of thing,
it helps with,
sort of, what I mentioned before,
which is just, like, the legibility
of these levels,
so that a lot of the,
the more,
the enemies on the ground,
yes, you will see them coming,
they're still definitely
the ones that sort of
come in in waves
that aren't tied
to the scroll screen,
the scroll speed,
but I, I think that helps
just with getting a handle
on everything and levels like
that cave
where the walls
will close in on you
would be impossible
if it was,
like, a normal speed.
100%.
Yeah, you get, like,
what, what feels like
in real time
a lot of extra time
to react to things
that are ahead of you
than you would
in, like, a Gradius or something.
Sean, you mentioned the enemies
on the ground
and that is a good segue
for us to talk about
that not only is there
a variety of different
types of enemies, there's different ways
ways to fight these enemies.
The enemies on the ground
require a different input
than the enemies
in the sky
and so you shoot at objects
in the air with B
and on the ground
with A. We could get into
a whole discussion
on whether it should
have been flipped, if A should have been
for the air because it's,
you know, A for air,
that would have made sense.
I'm kidding,
of course. Yeah,
we are not, or bombs away
because you dropped the bombs down.
That's true. We're not going
to get into that today,
that could have been a one hour long podcast.
I was thinking the A button
is above the B button
on the NES controller
so A is up
and B is down. Are you looking at it
sideways? No.
Are you? No,
but if you do, yeah, the A is,
yeah, that's true, if you hold the controller
sideways, it would be above
the B button,
it would be north of the B button
to go back
to an old reference. Isn't it kind of
like on a diagonal where the A is up
above the B? No,
they're side by side. I must be thinking,
I mean, I'm playing
on a PlayStation controller. What Mad Cat's controller
are you playing with? I must be thinking
of the Super Nintendo controller.
we've been playing
the system for so long.
Yeah, that Joe forgot
how the controller looks.
Yes, you are thinking
of the Super Nintendo,
which is- You know what I'm actually
thinking of is the Game Boy.
Well, the Game Boy
is a ripoff
of the Super Nintendo. Is that so?
No. There's only two buttons.
The Game Boy Advance
is also not. It's a fucking ripoff.
The DS is the first one,
right, with the X and Y buttons.
The Game Boy Advance only had B and A as well.
But yes, you bring up a good point.
The Game Boy did have them
on like a slant.
So why didn't the NES?
But the NES definitely did not.
Well, I'll see that way out.
I say definitely did not,
but I'm-
No, I'm sure there was
like some kind of-
Right? Didn't the NES like the Nintendo
officially, not even like a bootleg,
they made
other controllers
and I think one of them
either like the NES Max
or Turbo
or something like that is what you're describing
where it is on a slant. that's what I was thinking of.
Definitely, yes. Yes,
the NES Max pad.
Everything's on a slant.
I just realized right now
that my right arm is longer than my left arm
so I actually hold the controller
at a slant. Oh.
Yeah, but do you see
what I'm talking about with the NES Max controller?
I just posted it in the chat for you guys.
Everything is on a slant
to accommodate Joe here.
They put the start and select buttons
on a slant. The turbo buttons
are on a slant. The directional stick
is a little different. It's a stick now,
not a pad,
not a cross. So that's cool.
Kind of hate it, to be honest.
Yeah, I like how they took
the picture of this slanted
so everything is actually straight
except for the controller
looks slanted now.
That's true, yeah.
Even NES Max
is slanted. Nintendo is slanted.
Enough, enough about the controller
because we have to go back to the game.
I said it could have been an hour long podcast
and we almost got there.
To go back to the game,
is it just like
another thing
to lay on to like
the game that,
you know, oh, there are enemies
on the ground and enemies in the air
or is it become,
does it become a management thing?
Does it make the game more challenging
as a result? Bolt,
you can't spam
the B and the A button
at the same time
and shoot Bolt
at the same time but I did find
that that did work.
Like, if you hit him
at the same time,
it'll be like the first shot
is the air shot,
the next shot's the ground shot
and so you don't even have to think about it.
That's a little bit of a cheat
but that also exists
as an option. I'm gonna shut up.
Sean, your thoughts
on air and ground enemies?
I don't really know
what my opinion was of,
like, because one of,
I feel like since we've been
playing shmups,
this has been
a mechanic that,
uh, that we played
around with and we just
haven't seen it in a while.
Um, but I,
and I don't know what my opinion
on it was then
but I would,
I very much like it
now because
it gives you
something else
to think about and you do have
to manage that
and you do have to change your,
uh, your approach
when there is
a, an aerial enemy
and a ground enemy
near each other. You have to,
uh, make sure that
you can actually
get both of them
and while that is
a very simple thing
and one wouldn't
really call taking care of
these things a strategy,
I think
having that
other action
that you have to do
is important
to, you know,
keep this stuff fresh because
we played so many
shmups that it's hard to keep fresh.
Yeah, and it also,
it adds to,
like, your feeling of agency
rather than it's just
like, oh, I'm just flying
and just holding down the fire button
and just anything
in my way I will shoot
and, you know, like,
yeah, you, you have,
you have some
thinking to do,
you know, and like,
you, you feel a little
more in control
of the dragon
and I think that this,
this style
has been cool in the past
when we've done, like,
games where you're a plane
and you're, like, bombing things
on the ground and shooting things out of the air
but something
particularly about being the dragon
and I think also,
like, combined with the slow movement
and the power-ups
really feels like
you are laying waste
to, like,
the aerial and ground enemies
like, you are, you are death
from above in this game
like, you feel very strong
especially when you
get those power-ups. Especially in
Paleozoic era, like,
I know that those,
that these Stegosaurus's
are shooting fireballs
at you like any enemy
in a shmup
but, like, you are just,
like, eradicating the dinosaurs.
Yes. And, and,
and they fire so slowly
that it almost feels
like that they're defenseless.
So, sorry,
that was just an aside. And you're rewarded
for clearing out
all enemies
because they're, it's not like power-ups
are just,
uh, things you find
on screen. They are,
uh, things that you blow up
whether they are glowing enemies
or, um,
pods you find on the ground.
I saw them as, like,
deflated balloons,
but yeah. Yeah, okay.
Um, yeah,
deflated balloons. That's paleozerogera.
That's where those, that's where those,
like, originated from.
We just happen to still
have them around, but they're a finite resource.
Most microplastics
were littered
by the T-Rexes.
Yeah, it's not my fault.
Birthday parties. It's not my responsibility.
Exactly. They had birthday parties
back in the dinosaurs. Yeah.
Okay, uh,
the power-ups,
uh, not only being,
like, oh yeah,
they're available both on the ground
and the air. Obviously,
you have to do crowd control anyway,
so they want you killing stuff,
but what I found interesting is that
the power-ups on the ground
are different than the power-ups
in the air. Yeah,
I couldn't really tell
what any of them
was specifically changing
aside from the ones
that, like, kind of show
either, like, a trident
or a bident.
And even then,
Sean, you're, like, still losing.
Like, you're not quite
understanding, like, there's not enough time.
Like, these power-ups come kind of rapidly.
Like, I felt like, I wasn't sure,
you know, is this, like, something where,
like, I have to keep collecting the same color?
Uh, you know,
we've played shmups like that,
where you have, you know, if you keep collecting
the blue ones, eventually you'll reach
the final form of that power-up.
Uh, here, it was like,
alright, I think I'm just gonna keep collecting
things and just let
my dragon go through
information like
no other. Yeah.
Like, the only reason
that I knew what those were for
is because they were semi-recognizable
and I noticed that
whenever I got them,
um, I would either have,
like, one, two, or three heads,
which is also awesome.
Um, playing as
a three-headed dragon
is cooler than playing as a two-headed
dragon is cooler
than playing as
a singular
headed dragon.
It's the King Ghidorah
game I didn't know
I needed. Exactly.
See, I'd go as far as
to say that I sometimes didn't even
really know what
the power-up I just
picked up did because I'm just
noticing, like, whoa, I'm,
like, I'm green now.
Yeah, yeah, and there's,
like, but, like, clearly it's doing
something. It's just,
like, sometimes, yeah,
you have the three heads, you're shooting
three projectiles,
sometimes you're shooting, like, multiple projectiles
out of each head,
and then the projectiles are,
like, huh? Sometimes you have,
like, little,
yeah, many, uh,
dragons following you.
yes, like,
that, every time I thought
that I was done discovering power-ups,
I would find something new,
but, like, but then there's also,
like, stuff with what feels,
like, changes the,
um, projectile speed,
which I'm assuming makes it more powerful,
and it just kind of all eventually kind of blended
together as, like, wow, I'm just getting way
more powerful in a lot
of ways. Yes,
but it, but it is hard,
right, Joe, to, like, keep track of,
like, all right, but now,
did that cancel out?
Like, by collecting this power-up,
did I lose, like,
how do I increase my
spread infinitely?
Is it just something
that I needed to,
uh,
dodge certain power-ups
and collect others?
I don't think, I guess I never,
I think there's,
there are certain, there are certain upgrades,
and again, this is just us talking
out of our ass, I think,
um, certain updates are just
linear, and you keep getting more,
and, like, that's,
like, your rate of fire,
um, I think there's health
pickups, right? Like,
those are just, like,
just keep picking them up,
um, and then there's the ones
that actually, like, change your mode of fire,
like, there's a W-shaped one,
and I'm pretty sure that one changes
your, uh,
your firing pattern
from straight ahead
to, like,
a cone, and then
there are the ones
that, like, oh,
do you, are you shooting double,
are you shooting triple, are you shooting singular?
I think those are,
like, they add to each other
as well, but I could be wrong.
And I found it really
interesting that there were
also, there was also a power-up
that just makes you smaller,
and gives you a smaller
hitbox. Yeah, that's funny, yeah,
I appreciate that.
It's not something that you'd see, because it doesn't feel like,
oh, I've gotten more powerful,
but you have, you do have an advantage now.
So is the verdict that
it's confusing,
but it doesn't matter,
because it's awesome? Yeah,
I'd say so. It seems like that's,
yeah. I feel like it's confusing
in a way that, yeah,
was not relevant.
It's like, if I were trying to figure out
what each things were doing,
yes, it's confusing, but I wasn't.
I was just like, cool, I'm more powerful.
Right, like, in a harder game,
a Gradius,
right, you would want to know
what every power-up does,
and you specifically choose
when to execute on a power-up
to, like, I'm going to add this to my arsenal now,
like, I collected enough of these,
I want another option,
or I want a laser now.
You need those for those levels,
because as soon as you die,
like, you lose it all.
In this one,
yeah, as soon as you die, you lose it all,
but, like, it's not that hard
to start getting powerful again?
Do we agree with that?
I did notice that,
like, when I would drop back down,
because it does do the Gradius thing
where you lose everything,
but, like, I, you're able to,
they do sprinkle upgrades
in the beginning of the level,
because there will be times
where you can't find any,
but, it's kind of front-loaded,
so you can at least get to something
manageable pretty quickly.
There are power-ups in the levels,
but then there are also power-ups
in between the levels,
too, exclusive to the blue dragon mode.
There are the maidens,
or maids, it wasn't clear to me,
they are like,
you have to do a certain thing,
so that at the end of the stage,
they can grant you,
like, a special power,
and the first area,
it always appears regardless,
just to, like, let you know that they exist,
but then in the other ones,
there are, like,
certain conditions
that you need to meet
in order for them
to restore your energy
or give you an extra life.
It's pretty cool. I,
uh, I definitely read
these cutscenes,
and I didn't,
like, catch,
does it tell you
what you have to do for the next one?
Unfortunately, no.
Oh, okay. It's not even in the manual,
I checked there as well,
uh, I had to go to GameFAQs
to find out, and,
uh, it is a little arbitrary,
it's not, it's more like,
not something,
I would think that in a game
that wanted to reward you
on an end of level thing,
you know, especially, especially when it's like,
it would inform you? Well,
yeah, not even just inform you,
but, like, also make it something,
like, skill conditioned based,
like, oh, 90% accuracy,
right? Like, so you didn't just spam
the fire button all the time.
Oh, yeah. Or,
or destroyed this many,
uh, enemies,
or had this many points,
right? But instead,
it's like, if your dragon had less than
three heads, it'll restore your energy,
because I guess it assumes you're worse off,
if you didn't have,
like, the full power up,
you know? That's not what I wanted,
when I saw, when I saw those results.
So wait, so,
like, they are,
they are just restoring your health,
or there are actual abilities
that they give you?
No, they don't give you new abilities.
They're, they're restoring or giving you extra lives.
I got you. So I had,
like, a couple times where it says,
like, where whoever it was said,
like, oh, I'll restore your health,
but I didn't know why.
It maybe happened, like,
once or twice, and then I just assumed it was happening
all the time, and they just weren't calling it out,
but I guess not.
I guess I just missed those things.
Yeah, you must have not have met the conditions,
although you will still meet the,
like, shadow version of,
of the maiden. Oh,
that's why they weren't colored in.
I see. Yes, yeah,
it's like, you,
it's letting, the game's letting you know,
again, cryptically, that you didn't meet the criteria,
that they won't tell you.
So, probably,
uh, I don't know,
is, is that what you want?
Like, shouldn't it just restore your energy
regardless between stages?
I don't think it needs to,
but I think they need to communicate
what you need to do
to do it,
you know? Like,
yeah, I think that's the only issue here.
Yeah, definitely. It's,
it's, it's just one of those things,
especially like, before the age of the internet
or anything like that, it's just,
it's just kind of not fair.
Who would figure it out
just randomly?
Like, that's not, that's not good gameplay.
And Joe, were you advocating for the maidens
giving you, like,
new permanent power-ups
of some kind? Um,
I mean, that would be cool.
It's not necessarily what I was advocating for.
It's just what I thought you meant.
So, I was just clarifying.
Because I didn't know
that there was this,
like, condition you had to meet
to, so I thought it was maybe like,
oh, you get this secret power-up
or something. Like,
I feel like it would be, I would be more okay
with the not knowing,
even though I'd still wish
that you wouldn't know
what the condition was,
but I'd be more okay with the not knowing
if it was like this secret,
really cool power-up.
If it's just to restore your health,
like, there should be a way to do that.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
It feels like, if you're going to make it hard
to unlock in the first place,
it should be a bigger reward,
but whatever. And it is only locked off
to the blue dragon mode,
so I guess they determined that
in the gold dragon mode,
it's easy enough that you won't be needing
these extra lives and such.
They're really insulting.
You know what else is insulting,
Sean? What's that?
they didn't use the select button
for anything in this game.
I mean, you don't have to use
the select button.
Do you need to use
every button on a controller
in order for your game
to be worthwhile? I don't think so.
I don't think so at all.
In fact, there are games
that only use one input
that are just as,
that are just as good.
Well said, Sean.
Not that one. I had in my notes,
yeah, I had in my notes here,
the debate continues,
but it seems like you have,
uh, just closed the argument
altogether. Nobody can dispute that.
Was this an existing debate?
It wasn't an existing debate.
The debate actually was more about like
the select button
being a pause button
versus selecting a mode.
Right. I, I think the,
the worst thing
that they could have done
is that the,
the A to shoot.
You select is fire. Yeah,
or no, yeah, like to shoot on the ground
versus shooting in the air,
you have to select.
Oh God. Now you're in air mode.
And now you're in ground mode.
Um, that would,
you know, and then A and B
are just to shoot out
of each head. Like A shoots out
of the main head, B shoots out
of the side heads.
I like that. It's sort of like
an akimbo thing.
For the rest of the story,
we talked about the cool opening thing
where it's like either dad dies
and you take up
the mantle or not.
Uh, did you follow the story
the rest of the way? Did you care anymore?
It feels like
it's very front loaded.
Uh, similar, similar.
This is a weird sentence. Dragon Spirit,
the new legend, feels like its story
is front loaded in a way similar
to Chippendale Rescue Rangers.
Ah, yes,
the, uh, the archetype
for front loaded,
uh,
story content. Yeah,
it's like a metroidvania.
It's like a, it's like a castle
or dragondale.
Or, uh,
castle of dragon.
Wow, we got there.
Um, I would say that
I couldn't follow it
even though it was very simple.
Like, they, they're giving me
a bunch of names already.
Like, is Iris my sister?
Did I save my sister?
Is that what we did?
Yeah. Okay.
Then I did follow it.
Yeah, you're like,
uh, Luke and Leia, you know?
You were confused,
so you were actually
probably attracted to Iris,
but then found out later on
that she's your sister.
I was retconned
to being my sister.
Um, following the story,
I mean, yeah, I, I was like really into it
at the very beginning. I was like,
this is like epic and it's like this,
yeah, this actual legend,
I guess it makes sense.
Uh, and I did sort of like,
I still thought it was cool going on,
but I was like, okay, cool.
This is fine. And I just like,
didn't really care so much like by the end.
On the sequels
and spinoff side,
so Dragon Spirit,
no subtitle,
is a, uh,
arcade game
and, was ported to a bunch
of other ones too, but the NES one
expands on the,
um, like,
concepts a lot
that were in the first game,
so it's not a port
of that first game,
but it's also not a port
of that first game because of the story additions.
So, the new legend
both refers to
the expanded story
and, um,
the extra levels
mechanics and, and things that were introduced.
So, the arcade,
you know, is cool for a different reason.
Like, it, it still works,
but it's more basic
and, uh,
you know, a lot older
than the NES game.
On the,
uh, actual sequel side,
there's Dragon Saber
After Story of Dragon Spirit,
uh, which is weird,
right? Uh, it's called After Story?
After Story of Dragon Spirit.
Yeah, it feels like someone at Square
got their hands on this.
Wait, specifically After Story
of Dragon Spirit?
After Story of Dragon Spirit,
right, that's what I'm saying, that's where it gets confusing.
Just call it Dragon Spirit
After Story,
right? Like, Dragon Saber
After Story?
Yeah. Yeah,
Dragon Spirit 2 sounds better.
Like, After Story,
it sounds, yeah,
you're right, it's very much
birth by sleep. I,
you know, maybe that's why
I do sort of like
After Story, it sounds kind of cool to me.
You would. But Dragon Saber,
like, I don't know,
like, I wouldn't think
that this is a sequel
to Dragon Spirit,
right? Like, you don't just continue
to change, like, you don't change.
It's not the Dragonverse,
you don't,
you're not the only game
that has Dragon in the title,
so, don't pretend that you do.
The quote here I have
about Dragon,
it's Dragon Saber,
is he talking about? Okay.
Namco artist,
Shugiyama,
said that he basically wanted
the game to appeal to anyone
instead of mostly
hardcore shooter
enthusiasts,
and one that many
could find a degree
of satisfaction in.
So, it explains that
it's not just us
being good at the game,
they literally
made it easier
to appease the masses,
us being part of them.
Sounds about right.
It seems like a concerted effort,
there being, like,
a full, like,
not baby mode,
but I guess it's the,
like, as closest as you can get
to a baby mode
in an NES game.
And Dragon Saber
allows you to
co-op
the campaign now,
so you can have a blue dragon,
and your friend
can control the red dragon,
and they don't do
anything different from each other.
And we're not about
to do anything different
on how we end
this episode. We are going to end
this episode, like every,
with the Essential Games
List. Dragon Spirit,
the new legend,
is the best dragon game
I've played in the last four weeks.
And that much
I know to be an absolute fact,
but I also know
that this is
one of the best
shmups I've played
on the NES,
if not all
shmups. And I think it has
to do with how easy
it is, and that makes me
concerned for my sanity.
Am I just starting
to like games that are easy
because I've been playing so many
hard NES games?
That we will see
with time, but right now,
just given
the fact that this
game actually surprised me,
we're always talking
about, like, oh, you want the,
like a good video
game, a good movie,
a good, any kind of
entertainment. In life,
you want your expectations to be
subverted. And Dragon Spirit
really did that at the beginning
and then became
a very pleasant
game onwards.
Whether you're playing the Golden
Dragon easy mode,
again, maybe to Joe's point,
like you wouldn't even know that you
were playing the
easy mode of the game.
You thought like, oh, that was a scripted
death event. Or,
instead, you play the Blue
Dragon mode
and you're rewarded
with, a longer game,
but it's not an incredibly challenging
game and it's a
fun game. And you will die,
but you have lives
and you will make it
through it and I
will make it through this vote by voting
it essential.
Joe? I feel like a lot
of times we talk
about games that
come along and we're like,
okay, this was a really
good game, but it just didn't
do enough to,
like, spice itself up to
stand out. So,
like, it just didn't do enough to be,
like, this is definitely essential.
And, this was a
really good game and I think did
plenty of things
despite, I mean, like, we talked about
the music is beautiful,
the art and,
like, the different,
um, different,
like, enemy types and,
like, the styles of the
art there. And just the
gameplay, the story,
like, the whole package is really cool
and, you know,
as someone who usually isn't very
high on shmups, I really did like
this game. And granted,
uh, it's definitely in,
like, an atmosphere that
is maybe a little more catered towards
me anyways, but I think beyond
that, this was also one
of the most fun I had with a shmup.
I'm a little more
confident that it might be,
like, partially because
it was easier,
but also, um,
I liked it a lot.
Also, just want to clarify,
because, like you said, to Joe's point,
maybe you wouldn't
know you were playing the easy dragon.
Just want to clarify that I was
playing the hard dragon,
didn't know I No, no, I know,
I know. I know that's not
what you meant, but I wanted to
specify. Um,
but yeah, I'm going to definitely throw
this an essential
vote. Yeah,
I was just trying to change the
narrative that you're a good
video game player.
Yeah, exactly. I don't want
anyone to think that you,
um, can beat,
uh, all the final bosses
in Kingdom Hearts, uh,
three. I just got my
first platinum trophy on Kingdom
Hearts ever. Whoa.
Okay. Maybe you can.
Yeah. No, that's important.
That up, Sean. Yeah.
Sean, what have you platinum lately?
Or what have you
voted essential lately?
Will you join me and
Joe? It doesn't really
matter because we've
already decided it's
going to be on, but you can draw a
line in the sand if you wish.
Sean, your vote.
Um, okay.
I feel like that
was, that was, it doesn't matter
what you feel
like. Yeah. I felt like I've
said like a mean thing and then Mike
like went on to it. I was like, well,
now I feel even meaner because that
was kind of like, yes,
we ganged up. Very mean.
Uh, I think it's because
Joe defended himself
when he should have just like shut up
and, and been okay with,
uh, being called bad
video games.
No more. Yeah.
Um, but you know,
all that aside,
um, I,
you know what? No,
now I'm not doing
it. Um,
I actually hated
this game and
thought that how
surprising it was,
was really terrible.
Like I, like I hate being
surprised because
that means that I
don't know how the
world works. You know,
that means that I
like,
I can't say I
knew that would happen. Um,
okay, sorry.
It's done.
I, I was very
surprised by this
game. I thought,
you know, especially,
I think in the last episode we
were like, what do you think it is?
And like, Oh, it's probably another shmup.
And I was
right. And that was
kind of funny, but I didn't
realize it was going to be like
an actual good
shmup with actual
new things to do
and say. And,
um, we would actually
have things to talk about for
40 minutes that,
uh, aren't us just
sort of retreading other reviews with
kind of just forgetting what we
said in them. Um,
one of the most surprising starts to
a game I've ever played.
Um, the,
the music's great.
The, all the enemies
are,
they do weird
things in each
level and each
level feels different and more
just than just like
reskins. Um,
uh, and,
and again, just going back to
the beginning, the fact that
it diverts so
much, um,
like it just reminded me of a
more modern game.
and you might call me crazy for
comparing it this
way, but like in the
beginning of
Baldur's Gate 3,
I failed a skill
check and missed
one of like the
most beloved
characters in the
game and didn't
notice until I was
halfway through the game.
Um, it's not quite that,
but it reminded me
of that sort of
like blink and you
miss it. There's,
there's a lot of stuff going on here
kind of moments. So yes,
I'm going to also
call this an essential game,
um, so that it can be
unanimous. Um,
but in, in the future,
I will withhold
something like an
essential vote because
I've been offended in
some way. Hmm.
Good. Now you said a lot
of great things and I
had some comments about
some of the points you made,
but you talked for so
long that I forgot
them all. Good.
Sean, you know what would
really make me mad if
you wanted to offend me is
if you were to like throw a
vote at, Zelda two,
never disingenuine vote at
Zelda two. I would hate that.
Absolutely not. Yeah.
Cause then it wouldn't get there,
uh, for the right reasons,
Joe. Right.
Exactly. You would have to try to
take it off. Yeah.
Uh, all right. That's the episode.
It's been a good episode,
uh, for more good episodes,
tune in every Friday and
for great episodes of games
you probably haven't played,
check out nostalgia bites.
That's where we play games
from the Famicom and
potentially other libraries
as well. You can get there,
uh, to that podcast by going to
patreon.com slash
nostalgia. And,
uh, that little mistake there I
made at the end, you can tell that,
you know, I'm clearly just riffing.
These are not sales pitches.
These are just me talking to
you. Hopefully you're having a
great day or about to have a
great day, depending on what time you
listen to the podcast. Joe say,
have a great day. Have a great day,
everyone. And then Sean cover our
bases. Say, have a great night.
Sean's not speaking to you.
Yeah. He took it. This is,
this is how he gets us
back. Okay. Well,
that's fine. Uh,
cue the music.
Yes. Thank you.